you've seen elections for a long time
and they've
they've gone through different uh you
know uh uh conditions so whether it was
you know nixon first going to uh being
on tv to debate with kennedy i'm like oh
my gosh you got to make sure you look
good on tv when you're being you know
when you're debating was radio prior to
that
and now you got social media how much
has the game change for somebody that
wants to win a campaign
and who's who's done the best adjusting
to today's game being played
versus what it was maybe 20 30 40 even
50 years ago
well i think trump had a couple of
unique advantages
he had done a popular commercial
television series
called the apprentice i think it was on
for 13 years
he had he owned a one point
the miss universe contest until he was
very used to reaching a mass market
he really understood very quickly the
power of facebook and twitter
and so developed the largest following
uh in both
of anybody and as a result he's been
able to take on the entire national news
media
and basically fight him to to a
standstill because
his his reach has been as great as
the collective reach of every single
major uh elite news media it's a
remarkable achievement so i would say he
really understands it
you know biden is in a totally different
position biden basically is hoping
that kovid will win the election horn uh
i noticed that
you and i are talking on a day when
biden once again has no schedule
zero hiding in the basement uh in
wilmington
and you know but but it's not irrational
i mean his strategy
is that if he stays out of the way and
allows the country to be mad at trump
that he'll get elected because they'll
be trump so it's not a pro-biden
strategy
it's a hide-and-hope strategy it could
work i mean it's possible
partly because uh you know if your
opponent has
92 percent negative press coverage um
you don't have to do a whole lot
to communicate what's wrong because the
new york times the washington post
nbc and the rest of them they'll all go
do your job for you
and that's what's been going on